wir haben drei gut betagte weiße männer
im rennen unternehmen kann man als frau
mit indischen und amerikanischen wurzeln
und daneben frau was also wie groß ist
dieser pluspunkt darf man den gar nicht
unterschätzen oder es ist am ende so die
sympathie zählt und hillary clinton hat
es salopp gesagt auch nicht geholfen
sozusagen die erste frau jetzt fangen
eine alte weisen die sendung könnte gar
nicht authentischer sein aber ich glaube
es ist werden muss einen großen
unterschied hillary clinton hat für die
wählerinnen und wähler insbesondere den
swing states insbesondere den alten
industriegebieten einfach einen zu
elitären einen zu linksliberalen ja so
eine positionierung gehabt die fanden
das war nicht deren welt joe biden ist
unser hands down typ des normaler kerl
irgendwie und wenn der kämmerer harris
an seiner seite hat dann bringt es die
beiden großen elemente der
demokratischen partei zusammen und das
hat hillary clinton eben nicht vermocht
die leute mochten sie einfach nicht zu
schlagen zu abgehoben so käme der
harrah's wirft das keiner vortag von
kray jürgen trittin hat eben gesagt das
ist eine ehemalige staatsanwälte sind
die hat verbrecher gejagt dass das ist
ein super argument und es ist einfach
ein sehr gutes paket auf der
demokratischen seite dieses mal anders
als beim letzten mal ich finde das sehr
stark aber wie wichtig ist dass ihr
ebenso eine ganz andere note in diesem
wahlkampf bringt eben aufgrund ihres
geschlechts und ihrer herkunft sie
repräsentiert eigentlich amerika ist
tochter einer wissenschaftlerin die
zugewandert ist sie ist dort geboren
sie hat zum teil profitiert übrigens von
einer politik die man aktiv action nennt
also einer sozialen förderung von
benachteiligten an dieser stelle
sie steht mit ihrer ganzen geschichte
für einen dreistelligen zahl von
menschen die in amerika in den letzten
30 40 jahren eingewandert sind und dort
aufgewachsen sind und das ist sozusagen
wirklich der echte kontrast
auf der einen seite die republikaner die
versuchen sozusagen die vorherrschaft
der weißen auch um den preis der
vernetzung der institutionen mit allen
mitteln zu verteidigen und hier ist nun
eine mit einer erzählung sie ist
erfolgreich gewesen sie gehört zur elite
aber es ist noch diese alte traum vom
tellerwäscher zum millionär um zwei war
eben stärkung der nummer eins auf dem
ticket wem es das heute besser gelungen
pants oder herr es also ganz eindeutig
harris sie hat die kritikpunkte die
beiden an der an der regierung hat und
natürlich steko ohne die katastrophale
bilanz die tram zu verantworten hat hier
mittelpunkt die hat sie absolut
fokussiert und ich glaube diese chance
hat sie einfach genutzt
insofern war sie ich würde auch noch mal
unterstreichen wollen sie war natürlich
eine risiko kandidatur auch für beiden
sie zu wählen war ein risiko aber es hat
sich für ihn bezahlt gemacht diese
rechnung geht auf die bringt zusätzliche
wählerschaft die bringt so partie auch
bei weiblicher wählerschaft bei vielen
mit einem entsprechenden auch
migrationshintergrund den sie selber hat
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren